know you love radiohead and awful i love
radiohead uh as as does god yeah i do as
well
spawned over radio yeah i mean like i
had to like pick between muse and
radiohead and i was just like uh muse
cut [ __ ] just slightly edges of that
yeah because there's any radiohead songs
that i've heard that have been like i
love this song
have you listened to creep
i don't like creep though the best song
you guys always sing it
well i mean
this is like this it's it's like the
song because it's the least depressing
radio song yeah i don't really like the
depressing song yeah that's the weekend
scene
because at least it's gonna not be wrong
zombie yeah that's cause i started
listening to the lyrics i'm not gonna do
that again yeah yeah
um i don't know like i think for me
really hit i what i appreciate the most
about radiohead is that they started off
as just like another 90s like
alternative rock band and then one day
they were just like
no i don't think i will i don't think
i'll be another 90s alternative rock
band i'm gonna try something else and
then okay computer came out and it was
like one of the most like [ __ ] like
revolutionary 90s like rock bands ever
and then like bands like muse
listened to that was like we can do that
too yeah yeah exactly
like coldplay as well was like heavily
influenced by radiohead and like all
these like big
alternative rock bands that went a
little experimental yeah i mean i mean i
feel like radiohead all the og in that
sense and yeah you know they are they
are [ __ ] incredible and
the only reason i put music above them
was because like i think i discovered
them both at around the same time yeah
yeah yeah and i like but like there are
so many nights where i just like conk
out just listen to radiohead yeah and i
don't know it's to me if if i'm like
having an existential crisis i put on
radiohead man because there's nothing
that just like encapsulates that mood
more than just like a radiohead song
like sometimes i'm just like you know
what i just want to stay home and just
like
feel depressed
i wish i could feel this strongly about
music i did i remember i was at a place
that was like classical music being
played
and uh there was this guy uh i was i was
enjoying it that was amazing these guys
are so talented yeah and there's a guy
who's uh in the front and uh i could see
him because it was kind of like you know
like a circle in my semicircle you could
see him and he was like tearing up how
good this was yeah yeah i remember
thinking like [ __ ] how did he do that
how did he do that how does this mean so
much to him or how did that make him
feel this way because i don't understand
i like the sound a lot and i really
appreciated the artistry and everything
and i'm just like [ __ ] man i wish i was
just able to get what that guy had
was about like emotional about from the
from the music it like really made him
emotional i can i can easily yeah i
can't get that i think there's only i
think there's only two [ __ ] up i think
there's only two artists in my three by
three that haven't made me cry yeah yeah
i don't know is that weird that i can't
i don't think i don't i don't think it's
weird i wish i could get that like so to
me to me i have a different problem
because like i said i never know like
the deeper meaning behind the music but
like i've i've cried to so many songs i
have no idea what they're about
because they just make me feel things
i'm jealous i think i want to feel these
things
like i don't listen i don't know what
the lyrics mean i'm just like damn man
this i think like have you ever just
like
sat down and just listened to music yeah
and like but but i guess but i guess
you're listening to like darth bank and
[ __ ]
yeah it's not like digital love isn't
necessarily going to make you cry no
yeah no you're right i don't know right
it's just maybe the music i listen to
the way i consume it yeah maybe i don't
know but i don't think it's weird i
think there's a lot of people because i
i don't struggle to
i you know when i watch tv or anything
it's like super easy you cry all the
time but there are people who like
struggle to cry watching movies that's
right so i guess that's the same thing
so it's not like i'm sitting there like
[Music]
i don't get what this guy's getting i
don't understand why i you know maybe
it's maybe maybe maybe as i'm sure i
might yeah i mean like to me like music
is it's
going to sound so philosophical now it's
kind of like a language you know they're
like they're absolutely like i don't
speak it it is like
i feel like there is something being
communicated through the language of
music and like i don't even understand
the words behind the music but i feel
you know there are times when i think i
feel the language behind it and like the
emotion that is being portrayed with the
music
that's true i mean if if animals are
anything to go by you know dancing is a
language singing is a language somehow
they don't understand i imagine what
they're saying but it does something and
that's how they decided they yeah it's
just like pulls out like just some kind
of like primal yeah i think so i think
that we have an inclination to feeling
towards it yeah underwear
i [ __ ] like i don't know what makes
like i don't know what makes good music
like i i i don't know what makes good
music like literally i think what makes
good music is just if it makes you feel
a certain way i watch like musical memes
like
memes that only people who like or are
really into music would get and i'm like
i feel like this is funny i just didn't
i just couldn't understand why it was
funny right but like when somebody plays
like c minor or something like that and
i'll be like what
but yeah that was kind of funny that's a
bit of a deep cut but yeah i don't know
it is
something along those lines um and then
i guess like tulle is like
probably the one band that made me love
metal again right um because like do you
wanna run any of the songs
the name sounds extremely familiar i
mean they're yeah because joey just
talked about because like okay
that's probably why i talk about them
all the time but like i think like i
think what like speaking of like primal
instinct i think like tall does the best
job of like pulling out like that primal
instinct in people when they were oh i
thought you were talking about bamboo
monkey
that was like primal instinct i love
that
there's a man called primal scream which
is good but not probably um yeah i don't
know like tall is like i don't think
they necessarily have like a hit
song or anything they're kind of like
one of those just like cult bands i
guess maybe like the pot
yeah sober the port prison sex there's a
lot of like good songs but like i think
what makes it's like
i think what makes tool amazing and what
i fell in love with tall is that like
especially like this is a band that like
you need to listen to the lyrics okay
because it's like like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah like but what i love about tall is
that their music just in general is so
[ __ ] good that you'll still enjoy
yourself without listening to the lyrics
at all okay so like um manny james
keenan who's this guy in the middle he's
the lead singer um
in his in like tall stage shows and like
concerts normally the lead singer is in
the front right but maynard for some
reason is behind a curtain in the back
like you can't even see him half the
time in concerts and that's because he
treats his voice as just another
instrument and if you want to listen in
closely on what he's saying then you can
if you don't want to you don't have to
there's the rest of the band to listen
to and i think that's like so [ __ ]
cool because it's like
again it goes back to that whole thing
of like you might have like some deep
ass message behind your music but if
your music sucks then no one's going to
[ __ ] listen to it right sure and like
tulla's like we can make banger songs
and we can make profound lyrics that
make sense and it's like that's and like
i don't know it's just like musicians
it's like i i inspire to be that um and
yeah like i don't know like like tall is
one of those metal bands that like even
non-metal fans love
like i think every person i've shown
tall
who is like not necessarily into metal
music is like yeah this [ __ ] slaps
so like i'd recommend if you don't like
metal listen at all
um and then oh god i guess we'll go to
doctor doom has connor
mf2 i knew that i knew that um so mf
doom yeah uh
as as connor said is your favorite
rapper's favorite rapper i've seen that
youtube video yeah
i've
he's like a legend i i've heard so much
about this person but i've never
listened to their music yeah yeah so
basically like uh
tyler the creator and like you know
[ __ ] literally every like rapper
everyone loves and has gotten big has
been somehow inspired by mf2 just
because he's like i know he's like the
hip-hop fans hip-hop
if that makes sense
like because like i i feel like before
mf doom the only like hip hop i ever
really listened to growing up was like
eminem but that's because eminem back
then was like [ __ ] inescapable like
yeah during like eminem show era eminem
like
yeah eminem was everywhere right like um
so like i feel back then i didn't really
like take hip hop seriously or like
rapping seriously other than eminem um
but then i was in mf durb and i was like
okay hold on this might actually this
might this might actually be good
this might be some good music
um
again another artist you need to like
listen to the lyrics uh so yeah i
remember that i don't know who broke it
down was a vox or something vox did a
video breakdown
video and i was like this is amazing i
just don't i don't know yeah yeah i just
i don't know i i don't think i could
ever garner this by myself yeah yeah i'm
close to garnering this by myself it's
like when they tell you like why the
piano is this specific piano is amazing
i'm like i'm sure it is it certainly
looks the part but i don't yeah i don't
know yeah no it makes sense it makes
sense i mean it's just like good music
in general um again i'm having a hard
time explaining why this is good to
people who
aren't on the same
any hardcore music fans here can
appreciate your your tastes yeah well
okay well yes if if uh if we were more
hardcore into music how would you
explain it then i i because i am curious
um okay so break it down for me
focusing on 100 break it down okay so
tool for example um is like
like just this this sound and like this
singing style and the way they structure
songs is like it just has like a flow to
it like
one song could have like seven or eight
different parts that sound like seven or
eight different songs but somehow they
can stitch that [ __ ] up together and
make it sound so cohesive and like
together to the point where like you can
listen through a 15 minute tall song and
it'll sound like two minutes yeah i was
gonna ask how long is a typical tool
song
they're not actually two like i mean
they obviously have like long songs as
well but i think like average tall song
is maybe like five six minutes it's
quite long which i guess it's long but i
mean like if you compare it to like say
i don't know a tangerine dream song like
like it's like a standard tangerine
dream song is like 20 minutes that's a
good name yeah
i've never heard of them but that's a
good name so tangerine dream is this
german group uh yeah
yeah it's a great [ __ ] band name uh
so they're a german group uh that like
does like electronica and like ambient
music right and uh i put them there
because this is the one group i used to
listen to all the time in school while i
was studying how did you find out about
this band oh my god my dad showed me
okay i was going to say this but
i reckon everyone except maybe the
bottom three here i found it through my
dad all right um so like he yeah he's
just he raised you well man yeah
he's proud of you
um so tangerine dream haven't been
around they're still around actually
they've been around like 60 years almost
[ __ ] yeah i think they've been around
since like the early 60s in the store
yeah 1968 yeah [ __ ] hell and they're
still they're still going um they have
like i think they have like 400 studio
albums or something
they have a big big big catalog like
it's stupid amount of albums i've made
um but like basically they like really
revolutionize like chill electronica
like meditation music ambient music that
kind of stuff so it's like perfect study
material like because it's like there's
no lyrics better than lo-fly better than
lo-fi it should be that low-fi hip-hop
girl yeah look
hip-hop girl wishes they were tangible
um but yeah uh i don't know it's just
like really good like tangerine dream i
would say is like perfect background
music
of just like if you're like you know and
like if you have like friends over and
you're just like you just want to like
hang out or you're like you know you
have your [ __ ] like
i don't know fiance's parents over right
and you don't want to sound you don't
want to look weird by like putting on
like tall in the background you know
tangerine dream is like the music to go
right because it's just like it's just
relaxing it's inoffensive it's just i'll
check it out yeah and like they got like
a lot of good stuff they did a lot of
like uh movie soundtracks oh really yeah
there was this uh what was the tom
cruise movie that they did the
soundtrack too
um they did a lot of soundtracks though
um and like game soundtracks as well
that they're done
yeah yeah so uh what kind of games
i wish i could do they've done they've
done 400 albums
risky business yeah they did the risky
business soundtrack which is like
probably one of their best albums um
yeah they're just they're literally just
three german dudes who uh play a lot of
like relaxing goddamn they gotta [ __ ]
work out there